يعين لي اثار تلوث المياه في منزله
بسسكوهانا في بنسلفانيا نتيجه استخراج
الوقود الاحفوري المدعومي من الجمهوريين
وشركات الطاقه النافذه
ياملوا ان تتحول ولايته وهي من اهمه منتجي
الفحم والغاز نحو الطاقات النظيفه وهي
اولويه لبيض والديمقراطيين لكنه يرى ان
هذا الهدف لا يزال بعيدا
فيسبوك فيسبوك
يجب ايجاد ملكيه لوضع اطنان من الالواح
الشمسيه بينما تغطي الاشجار الكثيفه الشمس
ويجب قطعها بالنسبه للملاك لا يمكن القيام
بذلك فضلا عن انه سيكلف اكثر من 37 الف
دولار وانا لا املك ذلك
اكبر منتج للغاز الطبيعي وثالثه اكبر منتج
للكهرباء في البلاد كما تملك ثلاث مصافي
بترول بانتاج يقارب
270,000 برميل يوميا لكنها في نفس الوقت
رابع ولايه مصدره للانبعاثات الكربونيه
هنا تبرز الطاقه والمناخ قضيه رئيسيه بين
المتنافسين على انتخابات حاكم الولايه
ومقعد مجلس الشيوخ
الديمقراطيه
وجون بيترمان يدعواني لعمليات التنقيب
المسؤوله مع تعزيز التوازن بين الغاز
الطبيعي وتوسيع الاستثمار في الطاقات
البديله وهو موقف تؤيده استطلاعات المحليه
لبعيد وتسريع الانتقال فعليا نحو نظام
طاقه نظيفه ومستدامه والحفاظ على الموارد
المائيه لذا فان التناقض قوي مع النهج
الجمهوري وهذا يظهر جليا بين المرشحين
اما المرشحين للجمهوريان ضد مصريان وميمت
اوز فيدعموني رفع القيود على التنقيب في
الاراضي الفيدراليه بهدف تحقيق الاستقلال
في الطاقه وزياده التصدير بالنسبه
لكريستفر وهو نائب مهتم بامن الطاقه فيرى
ان القضيه باتت اكثر الحاحا في ضوء
تاثيرات الحرب الروسيه على اسعار الوقود
المحليه
باثار هذه الحرب فقد كانت تذكيرا بشان
الاعتماد على دول روسيا في النفط والغاز
لم يكن ذلك ما حل تفكير للعموم في الماضي
لكنه فتح الان اعين العالم على اهميه امن
الطاقه
اولوياته فقد وقع في اغسطس الماضي قانون
الاستثمار 370 مليار دولار
ان خطته للتحول نحو الطاقات النظيفه لكنها
تصطدم بالوضع العالمي حيث الطالب على
النفط والغاز يزداد داخليا وخارجيا
لا شك ان السيطره على الكونجرس تحدد
سياسات المناخ والطاقه خلال العامين
المقبلين فسيطرته الديمقراطيين ستعزز
طموحات بيضا للانتقال نحو الطاقات الخضراء
اما فوز الجمهوريين فسيكرس استمرار الوقود
الاحفوري مصدرا اساسيا للطاقه محمد احمد
الجزيره بن سلمان